So, similar to microkernel-based operating system
design that we have discussed before, functionalities
in the Tornado operating system are contained
in these clustered objects. And these clustered
objects have to communicate with one another
in order to implement the services. Because
it's not a monolithic kernel anymore, it's
a micro kernel where the functionalities contained
in these objects. And so we need efficient
inter process communication via object calls that go between
an object that can be a client, can, can be thought of as a client and an
object that can be thought of as a
server. For instance The FCM object may need to
contact the DRAM object in order to get a page frame. So, in that case, the FCM
object is a client and the DRAM object is a server that is serving the request.
And the way the request is satisfied is through the IPC realized by a protective
procedure call mechanism. And if the calling object
and the called object, the client and the
server, they are on the same processor then
Tornado use this handle scheduling between the calling
object and the called object. It's very similar
to what we discussed in the LRPC paper on
how we can have efficient communication without a context
switch. So local protected procedure call, you don't have
to have a context switch, because you can
implement this by handoff scheduling. Between the calling object
and the called object. On the other hand, if
the called obgject is on a remorte processor then
you have to have a full context switch
in order to go across to the other processor
and execute the protective procedure call. And this
ICP mechanism is fundamental to the tornado system. Both
for implementing any service as a collection of
cluster objects, and even for managing the replicas of
objects. So for instance, I mentioned that you might
decide based on usage pattern that I want to have
replicas of the region object which represents a particular
portion of the address space. If you have a
region object that is replicated it's equivalent to a
page table, has mappings between virtual pages and physical
pages. If I replicate it, then I have to
make sure that the replicas remain consistent. Whose job
is it? It is a job of the clustered
object implementation to make sure that replicas are kept consistent.
So, when you modify one replica, you have to make
a particular procedure called the other replicas to deflect the
other changes that you made In the first replica. So
all of these are things that are happening under the
collar, so the key thing that you'll notice is that
all of the management of replicas and so on is
managed in software, we're not relying on the hardware cache
coherence because the hardware cache coherence only works on physical memory.
Now if it replicated. The physical memory is not the same
anymore. But is a replica that is known only to the
software. The system software. So, to the management of the replica,
that is, that has to be managed by the operating system.